right the prime factorization of 75
write your answer using exponential
notation so we have a couple of
interesting things your prime
factorization and they say exponential
notation we'll worry about the
exponential notation later so the first
thing we have to worry about is what is
even a prime number and just as a
refresher a prime number is a number
that's only divisible by itself and one
so examples of prime numbers let me
write some numbers down prime not prime
not prime so 2 is a prime number it's
only divisible by 1 & 2 3 is another
prime number now 4 is not prime 4 is not
prime because it's divisible by 1 2 & 4
we could keep going 5 well 5 only
divisible by 1 & 5 so 5 is prime 6 is
not prime because it's divisible by 2 &
3 I think you get the general idea you
move to 7 7 is prime it's only divisible
by 1 and 7/8 is not prime 9 you might be
tempted to say is prime but remember
it's also divisible by 3 so 9 is not
prime prime is not the same thing as odd
numbers now if you move to 10 10 is also
not prime divisible by 2 & 5 11 it's
only divisible by 1 and 11 so 11 is then
a prime number and we could keep going
on like this people written computer
programs looking for the highest prime
and all of that so now that we know the
prime is a prime factorization is
breaking up a number like 75 into a
product of prime numbers so let's try to
do that so we're going to start with 75
and I'm going to do it using what would
we call it a factorization tree so we
first try to find just the smallest
prime number that will go into 75 now
the smallest prime number 2 does 2 go
into 75
well 75 is an odd number or the number
in the ones place is 5 is an odd number
5 is not divisible by 2 so 2 will not go
into 75 so that we could try 3 does 3 go
into 75 well 7 plus 5 is 12 12 is
divisible by
three so three will go into it so 75 is
three times something else and if you've
ever dealt with change you know if you
have three quarters you have seventy
five cents so if you have three times
twenty-five you have 75 so this is three
times 25 and you can multiply this out
if you don't believe me multiply out
three times twenty-five now is 25
divisible by you can give up on two if
if 75 wasn't divisible by two 25 is not
going to be divisible by two either but
maybe 25 is divisible by three again so
if you take the digits two plus five you
get seven seven is not divisible by
three so 25 will not be divisible by
three so we keep moving up five is 25
divisible by five well sure it's five
times five so 25 is five times five and
we've done we're done with our prime
factorization because now we have all
prime numbers here so we can write that
75 is three times five times five so 75
75 is equal to three times 5 times 5 we
could say it's three times 25 25 is 5
times 5 3 times 25 25 is 5 times 5 so
this is a prime factorization but they
want us to write our answer using
exponential notation so that just means
if we have repeated Prime's we can write
those as an exponent so what is 5 times
5 5 times 5 is 5 multiplied by itself 2
times this is the same thing as 5 to the
second power so if we want to write our
answer using exponential notation we
could say this is equal to 3 times 5 to
the second power which is the same thing
as 5 times 5